- Did you call each other?
- Yes, we did.
- You were like, you wear
your favorite burgundy.
- Yes--
- No, you're sitting down--
- Oh me?
- Next to
Okay.
- Yes.
With those earrings you look stunning.
- Well thank you!
- So beautiful.
- Thank you so much.
- Did you watch Mr. Rogers growing up?
- (laughs) why are you
so far, do we scare you?
- I know hey?
- Of course you do.
- Like you guys talk, I'll be...
- I know he grew up in
Wales, but you grew up here--
- I grew up in Brooklyn so yeah.
- You grew up watching Mr Rogers.
- Yeah, yeah I did, absolutely.
- (Audience member) Brooklyn!
- I like it, okay.
- Brooklyn is always in the house, yep.
- I love it.
And you watched it as a kid?
- Yeah, my brother and I,
we watched it all the time.
I mean, I joke around but, I was like,
was I preparing for this
since I'm five years old?
Like I remember, just all of it
and it's all attached to like
a really sweet time in life
where you didn't know
much about anything yet.
- Mhm.
- And he was sort of your
entry way into so much of like,
what is is to think about your feelings
or what it is to like-
- Life.
- Yeah, explore life in this really calm,
sort of, patient way.
- [Kelly] Yeah, so, who do you play?
What's your role in the movie?
Tell everyone.
- I play Andrea.
I'm his ball and chain.
And our relationship is this-
Its in a complicated place,
you know , I think with relationships,
you know, there's sometimes
these points where there's just
miscommunication and we're
just missing each other.
Like, we're both on two
different pages at the moment
and we're trying to get realigned.
- Especially when you bring kids in.
- Exactly.
And so now we have a newborn
and we're trying to get realigned
and it's not quite happening.
- I loved y'all.
Like, on screen together.
It was so well done, like
all the hurt, the laughing,
all of it.
It was just like, so well played out
to how actual relationships-
- Oh, good.
- How we interact with each other.
It was really good.
But you, you actually
have a really good, like,
neighbor story, like growing up, right?
Like, when you had your
land lady I heard about?
- Oh yeah!
You know what?
My land lady, bless her heart
and bless people who are like this.
I was so broke and just
trying to be an artist
and trying to stay true to my art
and my land lady in Brooklyn, Fredrica.
She'll love this.
She's an artist and she basically let me
stay in my apartment
because I was an artist.
And I called her one day, I said,
Look, I really can't afford
to be here, you know,
and I don't wanna hold
you up and I don't wanna
feel like I owe you.
So, Ill leave and I just
wanted to give you some notice.
She said, look, just stay.
I know what you're trying to do,
I know where you're trying to go in life.
Forget any late fees, forget,
like, any paying on time,
just when you can get it to me, get it.
You're a good tenent.
I'd rather just see you try and succeed
and you can stay in the place.
Isn't' that something?
- So remarkable!
- Amazing!
- Usually the land lady and
they're knocking on the door
I know you're hiding in there.
- Right, right, exactly!
- Yes, yes!
I mean not that I've done that.
(nervous laugh)
- And this is in Brooklyn
where prices are sky rocketing
and you can get anyone to come in
and pay double what I'm paying
and she just really invested in me
and that kind of thing,
you know, gets passed on
in some way.
I hope to do that for someone.
- I heard about that
story and I was just like,
"What a beautiful way."
and then you to take
that and pay it forward
for someone one day.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Its a beautiful
neighborhood kind of vibe.
- Very much so.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Did you get, I'm asking everyone.
Did you get the same gift
from tom Hanks at the end?
- Okay listen.
I was so happy you didn't
know what it was even-
- No, ah ah.
What I love is this coming out here.
- Here, on a public forum.
- Its my favorite.
- I know.
- How dare we not know what sir
Tom Hanks gave us as a gift.
- [Kelly] I know but it's -
- It's our fault.
Its our fault.
- Its so funny.
- Its either like, a riding,
like something to ride a
horse or something that's-
(heavy laughter)
- I am so excited about the guesses.
- It is so funny.
- It is, isn't it.
- Yes.
I realize now.
- Or you can put some - or
you can put paper in it.
I don't know, it's one or the other.
- I think it's for like loose sheet paper.
- [Kelly] This is just-
- Or tobacco.
- This is jus-
Tobacco! (laughs)
This is the greatest
quest I've ever been on.